Traduttore: Carolina Nocente
Revisore: Stefania Manunza
"Datti una possibilità, Matte!"
Non è una frase che
ho iniziato a ripetermi
davanti allo specchio
per caricarmi, no.
È una frase che Susanna,
una persona per me molto importante,
mi ha detto all'inizio di questo percorso
che ho intrapreso ormai due anni fa.
Me l'ha pure scritto su una bandiera.
Una bandiera che ha cucito mia madre
e che custodisco quindi oggi
gelosamente in un cassetto.
E la possibilità me la sono data.
Però non a me stesso,
l'ho data ad una visione.
E non l'ho fatto assolutamente da solo,
ma l'ho fatto proprio con la
partecipazione di tante persone
che in questi due anni
hanno, non so come,
deciso di camminare con me
verso la stessa destinazione.
E questa che vi racconto oggi
è proprio l'inizio,
la storia del nostro primo capitolo.
Come sono andate le cose?
Allora, facciamo un passo indietro,
andiamo nel 2009.
Mi laureo in Economia
alla Bocconi a Milano.
Subito da neolaureato
mi capita questa opportunità:
l'opportunità di lavorare
per la mia azienda di moda del cuore.
Avevo questa sorta di amore adolescenziale
per questo brand,
che in quel momento stava iniziando
il proprio piano di espansione globale,
e cercava dei managers da formare.
Mi offrono, da neolaureato:
un periodo di training a Londra,
un contratto a tempo indeterminato,
trasferimento a Milano
e possibilità di carriera.
Tutto fantastico,
se non fosse che in realtà
avevo già la valigia in mano
perché stavo per andare a Barcellona.
Ero stato infatti preso ad un Master
in un'università molto importante
in Europa.
Avevo già pagato
la prima retta universitaria, (ride)
bloccato l'appartamento,
guardo mio padre e gli dico:
"Papà, penso che il Master
possa aspettare.
Magari poi torno a studiare
tra uno o due anni, non preoccuparti."
Però quell'aereo quel giorno
l'ho preso, per Londra,
il Master non l'ho più fatto,
ed è iniziata così la mia carriera
nel mondo della moda, avevo 23 anni.
Mi trovo fin da subito catapultato
in un mondo che dire travolgente è poco,
perché inizio ad aprire
stores ed uffici in tutta Europa.
Divento uno dei portabandiera
di questo brand,
che scatenava una reazione euforica
nelle persone a livello globale,
tant'è che è difficile descrivervi
la passione con cui vivevo ogni giornata.
Ed effettivamente poi
le possibilità di carriera arrivano,
perché nel 2012
divento Senior Manager in Germania.
E nel 2013, ruolo importante,
Co-amministartore
per il Diversity and Inclusion Council,
che era un organo, un team globale,
con la funzione di favorire
l'integrazione interna dei dipendenti,
ma soprattutto favorire poi
l'integrazione del brand
in tutti quei paesi nei quali gradualmente
stavamo piantando le nostre bandiere.
In questo ruolo inizia così
un percorso diverso,
inizio a scoprire che in realtà il dietro
le quinte del fashion system globale
era in un po' diverso da quello
che avevo vissuto fino a quel giorno.
Mi rendo conto che non era così
tutto felice.
E nasce in me un senso di malessere
che viene amplificato da un fatto tragico,
accaduto proprio quell'anno:
il crollo del Rana Plaza in Bangladesh.
Il Rana Plaza era un complesso di edifici
che ospitava diverse fabbriche tessili
che producevano abbigliamento
per una trentina di brand famosissime,
sono sicuro che tutti voi in platea,
se aprite oggi il vostro armadio,
avete almeno una maglietta
o un paio di pantaloni
che sono usciti da lì.
Da quegli edifici che il 24 aprile 2013
purtroppo sono crollati,
e hanno ucciso 1138 persone
e ferite gravemente più di 2500.
Non si è trattato di un incidente,
questa è la cosa più tragica.
Si è trattato di una tragedia
assolutamente evitabile.
I palazzi già mostravano
segni di cedimento,
tant'è che i lavoratori stessi
avevano denunciato ai responsabili
lo stato di avanzato pericolo. Però
i responsabili avevano altre opportunità,
prima fra tutte continuare a produrre:
era impensabile smettere di produrre
quando c'erano queste richieste
sempre più pressanti
da parte delle case di moda occidentale.
Sia in termini di pricing,
che in termini di tempistiche.
Ma purtroppo quel giorno
quella scelta è costata la vita
a migliaia e migliaia di persone.
Mio padre si trovava in Bangladesh
quando è crollato il Rana Plaza.
Io ricordo di averlo chiamato,
e il pensiero che ho fatto allora
è lo stesso che custodisco oggi
e che rivolgo anche a voi:
ma quand'è che il prezzo dei vestiti
che andiamo ad acquistare
è diventato più importante
della vita delle persone che li producono?
[EN, donna FC] Comunichiamo
chi siamo attraverso i vestiti.
Ed è totalmente diverso da quello
che vorremmo comunicare su noi stessi.
Una volta avevamo un sistema
che non ha nulla a che vedere
con il settore della moda di oggi.
È stato reinventato.
(Donna che piange)
[Uomo FC] Che cosa significa in Bangladesh
pagare il prezzo per i vestiti economici.
[Donna FC] Questa enorme industria avida,
che genera così tanto profitto,
perché non è in grado
di sostenere milioni di lavoratori?
Il modello di business attuale
è assolutamente insostenibile
se non viene cambiato questo modello
non cambierà nulla.
[Uomo FC] Possiamo migliorare le cose.
(Musica)
(Fine della musica)
[Dal documentario "The True Cost"
di Andrew Morgan]
[MW] È difficile rimanere impassibili
quando si vede questo.
Quando sono usciti questi filmati nel 2015
io lavoravo già nel mondo della moda
da ormai 6 anni e mezzo.
Come cavolo è possibile che abbia
contribuito a creare tutto questo schifo
senza assolutamente rendermene conto?
Ero completamente ignaro di tutto ciò.
Quel senso di malessere
che avevo iniziato a sviluppare nel 2013,
diventa sempre più forte. E diventa
anche molto difficile nasconderlo.
La realtà oggettiva è che la moda
è diventata oggi nel mondo
la seconda industria più inquinante
dopo quella petrolifera.
Consuma una quantità
di risorse naturali e umane
ad un tasso esorbitante.
E quindi mi sono guardato allo specchio
e mi sono detto: "Ma Matteo, cavolo,
se non ci provi tu a cambiare le cose
oggi che ne sei consapevole,
chi altro mai può farlo?"
O meglio, se non ci proviamo tutti assieme
a ridisegnare un futuro migliore
di quello che ci si prospetta,
chi altro mai può farlo?
La realtà è che noi siamo nati e cresciuti
in un sistema già disegnato da altri,
ma questo sistema non funziona più.
Bisognava tracciare linee nuove,
tracciare una visione diversa,
percorrere un nuovo binario.
E alla fine la domanda che mi pongo è:
ma quand'è che c'è stata l'ultima volta
una vera e propria una rivoluzione?
Bam, questa, ragazzi
mi gasava tantissimo.
Non riuscivo a dormire la notte,
più pensavo a queste cose
e tante le domande,
tante le risposte che inizio a scrivere
e a buttare giù,
che diventano in qualche modo
il seme di un business plan.
E alla fine, preso dall'euforia, bam!
Sconvolgo tutti e decido di licenziarmi.
Lascio il mio ufficio a Monaco,
la mia carriera e il mio posto fisso,
e ritorno a casa, a Vicenza.
Per fare cosa? La rivoluzione.
Ecco, se prima non dormivo la notte
perché ero animato da questi pensieri
se volete anche un po' romantici,
ora non dormivo la notte
perché, ve lo chiedo anche a voi,
ma come cavolo si fa la rivoluzione?
Mi trovo in questa situazione
in cui diventa difficile
giustificare agli altri
cosa sto andando a fare.
L'unica certezza che avevo
era la mia visione.
La visione di creare un movimento
con delle persone, animate come me
dalla consapevolezza
che ciò che indossiamo
non ci rappresenta più
dal punto di vista valoriale.
Ed era necessario
lavorare assieme per creare
un modo di essere
completamente diverso, innovativo.
Capace soprattutto di rispettare
le risorse naturali ed umane
che stanno dietro a ciò che indossiamo,
al fine di garantire vita
per le generazioni future.
Non un progettino da poco.
Da solo non ce l'avrei mai fatta,
per cui mi rendo conto
che ho bisogno di compagni di viaggio.
E li trovo nelle persone a me più vicine.
Victor, che è il mio pilastro nella vita
da tanti anni, e Federica,
amica d'infanzia,
anche lei impegnatissima
sul fronte ambientale e sociale
con diverse organizzazioni.
Con loro scrivo proprio
il primo atto di questo percorso.
Decidiamo di fare un viaggio,
un viaggio in giro per l'Europa,
con uno scopo ben preciso:
piantare il seme della consapevolezza
in tante città diverse.
Con la speranza che in qualche modo,
parlando così alle persone,
queste si animassero come noi
e andassero a fare delle cose funzionali
e ad attivare il cambiamento positivo
per la moda.
Ed effettivamente succede questo.
Partendo in questo viaggio,
la cosa straordinaria è che
quella che era inizialmente la mia visione
in realtà era già diventata nostra
perché da solo ero passato a tre persone,
e tornato a Vicenza dopo 2 mesi e mezzo,
eravamo partiti da Bracellona, Biarritz,
San Sebastián, fino al Nord Europa
e poi giù di nuovo in Italia,
avevamo creato un movimento:
da 3 eravamo diventati 5, 10, 15, 20, 500
e da qui nasce Wråd.
Nasce questa community.
Inizialmente Wråd è il nome
che diamo alla nostra pagina Instagram
per comunicare le nostre avventure.
Ma immediatamente ci rendiamo conto
che diventa qualcosa di più.
Diventa l'aggettivo scelto dalle persone
che spontaneamente iniziano a dire:
io sono Wråd. Perché?
Perché anche loro sono animate
da questa voglia
di diventare "rebels with the cause",
proprio dei rivoluzionari come noi.
Tante sono le voci che si avvicinano
in questo senso.
Silvia, una delle voci più importanti
all'interno del movimento,
la incontro prima del viaggio,
la ripesco dopo,
e si avvicina a noi e dice:
"Io voglio investire tutta me stessa
per catalizzare questo cambiamento
e lavorare con voi".
E poi Alvise, Matteo, mia sorella Anna,
Alberto, Santiago, Michelle,
son tante le voci che trasformano
questa voce un vero e proprio ruggito.
Un ruggito che portiamo dentro le scuole.
Perché tra il 2015 e il 2016
decidiamo di collaborare con le scuole
per parlare ai ragazzi di queste cose.
Partendo da un liceo poco distante da qui,
il Liceo Classico Antonio Pigafetta,
realizziamo un progetto educativo
oggi disponibile in 92 paesi nel mondo.
Avevamo tracciato la nostra strada.
Piantando il seme della consapevolezza
eravamo riusciti gradualmente,
e lo stiamo facendo tuttora,
ad alimentare questa voglia di cambiamento
funzionale allora, all'inizio del 2016,
per portare Wråd ad uno stadio
di sviluppo successivo.
Perché dall'ispirazione, a un certo punto,
diventa impellente passare ai fatti.
E questa voglia di cambiare si diffonde.
E avvicina a noi tante realtà industriali
che iniziano a fornirci dei mezzi
per portare sul mercato
non tanto dei prodotti da vestire,
ma dei beni originali, accessibili,
innovativi, sostenibili,
ma allo stesso tempo
reale riflesso del nostro manifesto.
Tantissime le storie
che nel 2016 attiviamo in questo senso.
Ma una fra tutte ve la racconto
perché è molto curiosa e simpatica.
La storia è legata all'economia circolare.
La moda consuma tessuti,
sostanze chimiche, energia e acqua
in quantità spropositate.
Perciò da mesi ci interrogavamo
su come cercare di realizzare qualcosa
che fosse funzionale
ad amplificare questo messaggio
e a parlare di questo problema
ad una massa di persone più ampia,
e allo stesso tempo capace di risolvere
in qualche modo il sistema.
E l'opportunità mi arriva quando Susanna,
la stessa delle bandiere
di cui vi ho parlato all'inizio,
un anno e mezzo dopo mi fa:
"Matteo io svariate tonnellate
di polvere di grafite di scarto".
Il perché Susanna le abbia
è un'altra storia.
"Ma, non so, secondo te
c'è una possibilità di applicarla,
c'è una possibilità di riutilizzo
nella moda, nel fashion?"
Io non lo sapevo,
giro la domanda a Silvia,
esperta di tintura,
e Silvia effettivamente scopre
che, 2000 anni fa, i romani già tingevano
con la grafite.
Oggi la grafite invece viene buttata via.
Straordinariamente scopriamo anche
che questa pratica non era finita
in epoca romana,
ma delle donne di un paese
a noi ora molto caro, Monterosso Calabro,
l'avevano tramandata
di generazione in generazione
fino ai giorni nostri.
Loro erano le uniche depositarie
di questa conoscenza.
C'era solo una cosa da fare a quel punto:
riprendiamo gli zaini dell'anno prima
e andiamo a Monterosso Calabro per vedere
come si tingeva con la grafite.
(PARLA IN DIALETTO CALABRESE)
(EN) Aspettate un minuto.
Torniamo alla storia per un secondo.
(MUSICA) Tanto tempo fa,
ai tempi degli antichi romani,
come narrato dagli storici, gli uomini
cominciarono a tingere la stoffa
usando un minerale
scuro e prezioso, la grafite,
che era presente in abbondanza
nella città di Monterosso Calabro,
nell'Italia meridionale.
(MUSICA)
Dalla tradizione all'innovazione,
abbiamo deciso di reinventare
questa tecnica meravigliosa riusando
lo scarto della polvere di grafite.
(MUSICA)
A volte devi fare un passo indietro
per poter andare avanti.
(IT) Nasce così, facendo un passo indietro
nella storia, GRAPHI-TEE,
che è stato il primo "purpose product",
un prodotto con un obiettivo,
che nasce per raccontare la storia
di forme alternative di tintura,
e in questo caso fanno economia circolare
perché partivamo dalla grafite di scarto,
ma allo stesso tempo diventa,
negli ultimi mesi,
il mezzo attraverso cui abbiamo finanziato
un programma di ricerca e sviluppo
che ha portato questa forma di tintura
ad uno stadio di innovazione successivo.
Tutte le persone che hanno deciso
di vestirsi di GRAPHI-TEE
hanno infatti supportato la ricerca
per arrivare al deposito di un brevetto,
per una forma di tintura
ancora più innovativa,
per un tessuto che è altamente inquinante,
il denim, quello che abbiamo addosso
quando vestiamo con dei pantaloni jeans,
e questa forma di tintura è straordinaria
perché ci consente proprio di ridurre
l'impatto ambientale
in termini di consumo d'acqua,
sostanze chimiche ed energetico
del tessuto dell'85%.
Ecco, l'85% da solo come dato
forse non vi dice niente,
ma basta che vi dica
che un singolo paio di jeans
può arrivare a consumare
fino a 9000 litri d'acqua,
e ci rendiamo conto della novità
che ha portato GRAPHI-TEE.
Non solo a noi, ma per l'industria intera.
Ecco una novità che è scaturita
da una situazione di crisi.
Ed è questa la cosa importante.
Qualche mese fa ero ad una conferenza,
e una persona che mi ha ispirato
parlava delle tre grandi crisi
che ci troviamo a fronteggiare oggi:
c'è una crisi spirituale,
ricerchiamo sempre nuove ideologie,
c'è una crisi sociale ed umanitaria,
c'è una crisi ambientale.
Io credo che nella loro drammaticità
queste crisi sono la nostra chance
di progresso, la nostra opportunità
di ridisegnare nuovi modelli di business
capaci di riportare la persona
e il pianeta al centro di tutto,
e non più un consumatore
avido di consumare prodotti
in quantità sempre maggiore.
Questo è il futuro per me,
il futuro è fatto di consapevolezza,
è fatto di partecipazione,
sia da parte di chi produce
che da parte di chi consuma.
Quando noi indossiamo dei vestiti
non indossiamo soltanto degli oggetti,
indossiamo la storia delle persone
che li hanno fatti
e la storia della natura
che li ha portati sul mercato.
Possiamo continuare a scegliere
di vestirci in modo irresponsabile,
oppure possiamo scegliere di vestirci
con qualcosa
che ci rappresenti nello spirito.
Uno spirito che noi chiamiamo Wråd,
uno spirito che trova l'entusiasmo
nella realizzazione che il cambiamento
sia veramente possibile
e possiamo realizzarlo noi tutti assieme.
Grazie al vostro coinvolgimento,
grazie alla scelta di tutte le persone
che da domani possono decidere
di indossare non più dei vestiti,
ma degli oggetti che in qualche modo
abbiano una coscienza, una prospettiva
e ci consentano di guardare al mondo
senza vergogna e senza sensi di colpa.
Vogliamo darci questa possibilità assieme?
Grazie.
(Applausi)